little thing my egg boys oh yeah I'm
segment first up it's Chris D'Elia again
I'm walking out he got another tattoo
incentive as he said he didn't even do
those tattoos he said that already
Shapiro hacked is no this is Papa Bear
from New Jersey Papa Bear has a lot of
honey do pop there is obviously trying
to hide the fact that he is blatantly
Amish okay
it is so Amish can we pull up Amish man
can we bring up honey booboo can bring
up a honey Boone's Farm
you'll definitely you get Amish man he
definitely has the Amish beard vibe he
does have a beard trim I think it's
trimmed up though let's get that guy
over there to the right with the thing
on his neck that's him right there
no with that with the thing on his neck
the red thing gang it looks like me also
there we go that is your boy right there
coming in hot bra man gypsy rude Louie
CK's new look is sick can't wait for his
new hour
yeah his new hour dude it's called
sunset bro all right let's get back into
it man see this honey boo boo Papa
what's up Bruno Theo what you guys sync
my ink they call me Papa Bear baby and I
have this Otis a swallow
Raven baby slam the Papa bears mouth
just a Papa baby there's some watercolor
very colorful tattoo for a big guy like
myself my money man tattoo right here
I'll do sales muddy mutts in my right
hand I make with beautiful aqua money
green rose for the money did that make
shaking hands doing business dollies
doing you have this dagger good oh yeah
oh yeah the blood helps with the
business you nervous yes your bank
teller finished
oh oh lighthouse or is that I dick dick
island that barely leaves don't a bunch
of skittles
yeah kako slot something for cockeyed
[Laughter]
hey boy Papa Bear got that if I need I
think I like this little too much honey
estate that Bears thrown up all them
rainbow skittles into [ __ ] crow I got
some questions that's the most random
get a giant bear throwing up [ __ ]
Jolly Ranchers into a crow yeah
and it have a bird I was everybody
didn't have a bird catch him in your
mouth right above the oboe dude that CPC
was great bro I don't know how much
needlework this guy had but he could
easily have vhi bro you know some of
this seems like the dark art bro that
bear that bear looks like a brother that
was in a fire first of all the hairy
honest dude it looks a little risque
[Music]
a lot of colorful you know the green
rows of money okay you gotta make sure
you guys angels well you get some honey
just drip it off your shoulder ah yeah
nobody's gonna believe that honey
dripping on your face big [ __ ] boss
cheats what I'm saying is this big guys
like and if you look right here they got
a mountain range with a barrel full of
cinnamon rolling they narrate it like
it's Morgan you can see there'll be a
lighthouse right thank you hell right
there hope you guys don't say anything
about looking like a cop and that dig
that you in I'll get roasted baby we got
a lot house with a couple of radish
plants around yeah and there's a femur
at the bottom of femur out of school nah
man I think this is uh what I'm trying
to say is dude I think this is it looks
good bro I think it's crazy to let
somebody draw on you in a small building
dude that's the only thing I don't her
said about tattoo places you know
but respect bro I got one dude and uh
and maybe one day I'll share but um but
yeah I like that I like this shipment
you got the Styles Papa Bear Dog yeah I
like them hairy shoulders see that's
[ __ ] stay on Papa beer that edgy
Amish brought you the edgy Amish don't
get that manscape 3.0 and try shaving
your shoulders you let that [ __ ] grow
bro like a Papa Bear keep the color -
they're gonna tell you don't go color
but I like it man yeah I think if you
let some of the hair grow in and then
make that part of the foliage Dada hair
green so what I would do is I grow on
what I would know this is what I would
do I don't wear the skulls that just let
the hair grow here so it looks like a
full human Copic while Vernon always
seen [ __ ] I thought lighthouse is a
place your thoughts to get to okay you
thought shutter island' yeah I thought
[ __ ] Thailand you thought shutter legs I
want some of that wiener
tell Big Dawg battleships showing up huh
that ship sunk bout to pop up man yeah
really you just ripped that guy you're
drinking out of that empty can again to
you what are you talking about bro I
don't know dude you went bad on Papa
Bear - man I did not that's a beautiful
I can't be a man shut up to your neck
beard I like all that beard is ice cold
man but shut I'll sing money thanks for
sending it in Nick they know we're gonna
rip it up when they send it right yeah
yeah we're gonna sink it okay raise my
[ __ ]
back off my broccolini get your life
together
I'm not touching